and i want to turn now to the aftermath
of the schauvin trial
an alternate juror is finally speaking
out about the sense of fear
she and her colleagues felt here's what
the juror in question lisa christensen
told cnn yesterday
i was concerned for my safety to a point
depending on
you know we hadn't heard any facts or
anything yet so depending on
which way it went um i felt like some
people
you can't please everybody all the time
so i felt certain groups might feel
certain ways
so i was a little concerned about that
she was even more explicit in an
interview with a local reporter saying
that
i felt like either way you were going to
disappoint one group or another
i didn't want to go through rioting and
destruction again and i was concerned
about people coming to my house
if they were not happy with the verdict
joining me now is alan dershowitz
harvard law prof emeritus
host of the durst show podcast his new
book the case against the new censorship
is just out coming out alan it's hard
to imagine that sense of fear didn't
impact the jury in some way
but we won't know i guess we'll never
know your thoughts
well first of all we should know there's
no reason why the judge shouldn't have
called in every single juror after
congresswoman waters made her statements
the judge said it was giving you an
appellate issue why not call in the
jurors
and ask them do you know about this
statement have you heard about it
are you afraid do you have the kind of
fear that if you come out with a verdict
that will not please someone
it could cause riots i have absolutely
zero doubt that jurors in that jury room
were worried about their own welfare if
they were to come to a conclusion
that murder was not committed if they
had come to a verdict either of
manslaughter
or not guilty they would worry that
their own welfare their children their
businesses their schools their
neighborhoods
would be burned down and by the way they
weren't the only ones who were worried
every police chief
every mayor the president of the united
states said that the jurors were under
enormous pressure that's not the way our
system is supposed to operate jurors are
supposed to be
isolated insulated they should have been
segregated they should have been kept in
a separate hotel room
during the entire process and never
should have been allowed to hear what
people like maxine what is now harpton
was threatening
alan the real really quick question are
you concerned
about a a precedent being set
with this trial with future trials of
people police officers others whose
outcome becomes a big i mean doesn't
this set
its own precedent we already see that
with kim potter who committed no crime
whatsoever
having been charged with manslaughter we
see it with the other
three accessories we don't know whether
they'll get a sequestered jury
the trial is ruled to take place in
in minneapolis that's a mistake
it's going to be very hard for the judge
in that case to make a decision whether
to sequester because
if the judge sequesters it will be a
slap in the face to the judge in the
shoving case
if the judge doesn't suggest her people
didn't even learn his lesson
the constitution i don't think we we
want terrified jurors
okay terrified jurors are going to be
under enormous pressure to come down
one way or another and not necessarily
according to the facts of the case the
evidence developed alan
thank you